[Musique]
ce matin ce n'est ni le froid ni le vent
glacial qui va freiner les amoureux de
la pêche hivernale à taquiner le poisson
sur les rives de lance à Benjamin
bonjour Rémi Aubin pêche sur la glace
depuis qu'il a 7 ans passionné par cette
activité il est la référence en ville et
notre guide pour la journée
moi je suis ici là
pourriez-vous
oui
au début ce que je fais c'est que je
bouge de base en haut comme c'est ici
pour l'attirer
aujourd'hui on pêche le sébaste un
poisson coloré à l'image des gens de la
région
différentes des formules un petit peu
différents ils sont toutes uniques en
soi c'est pour ça qu'on dit qu'il
représente un peu les gens d'ici
la récolte est bonne
moi j'ai jamais vu ça vraiment on parle
de 80 à 85% des poissons de fond dans
5000 ce sont des sédastes le sébaste
n'appartient qu'à celui ou celle qui l'a
péché le troc et la vente en sont
interdits
par jour
[Rires]
et des poissons qui vivent ici qui sont
plus gros que nous il y a des requins du
groenlands atlantiques des poissons qui
peuvent aller jusqu'à 700 livres
qui est extrêmement profond on parle des
endroits qui font plus de 950 pieds de
profondeur la particularité du fjord
c'est qu'on peut pêcher des poissons
d'eau douce comme les perlins qui vit en
surface et des poissons qui vivent en
profondeur dans l'eau salée comme le
Sébas le turbo et la morue franche
belle
morue là on en voit beaucoup cette année
de la petite morue comme ça
c'est un bon poisson
Rémi la pêche blanche ça représente ente
on parle de près de 8 millions à
retrouver économique
ils vont prendre une chambre d'hôtel ils
vont manger au restaurant il va acheter
des articles de pêche peut valoir
plusieurs centaines de dollars tandis
qu'un basse qui est pris dans un bateau
lui il vaut quelques dollars et tout
nous on a une valeur inestimable une
richesse que les pêcheurs sportifs
devront bientôt partager puisque la
pêche commerciale du Sébas devrait être
permise dans le fleuve d'ici quelques
temps avec sa chair blanche ce poisson
de l'avenir pourrait facilement faire
compétition au pangasius et outils la
pierre
et c'est un poisson qui peut vivre plus
de 80 ans il est tellement bon à manger
c'est tellement un poisson qui est
succulent moi souvent
je le fais accueillir seulement
goût à lui mais des fois il y a des
chefs qui ont des secrets là
du chef Jean-Denis Boivin
on est à la cabane il faut que ça soit
facile très simple très bon mais on est
du plaisir c'est ça
des fois la chance
pas question d'aller à la pêche sans
tenter ma chance
il faut que il faut que ça pique il faut
que ça rentre dans la gueule
c'est vraiment préparer les ingrédients
ou légumes al dente qu'on va faire
revenir dans le bikini qui va être en
guise d'assiette pour pour cet
après-midi préparez-vous c'est la canica
c'est pas grave
il va peut-être se passer de quoi
super
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on commence à avoir des jeux de belles
coloration comment ça nous plaire c'est
vraiment une cuisson minutes on ajoute
nos carottes nos pommes de terre le
bacon le fromage anobli j'aime bien la
cuisine authentique la cuisine de
grand-mère comme on peut dire la mangue
grillée puis il va être un bon
accompagnateur 92 sapins je vous laisse
vraiment vous faire découvrir
j'ai l'eau à la bouche
on va redécorer peut-être de violon
mariner
merci merci pour tous les efforts
merci pour l'invitation merci beaucoup